ukrainian president vladimir zorensky
has accused russia of genocide after
hundreds of bodies were discovered in
the town of butcher near the capital
kiev images of mass graves and bodies
showing signs of torture have sparked
widespread international condemnation
with several eu countries now pushing
for tougher sanctions against
russia moscow claims the killings were
staged our next report contains some
disturbing images
bodies line the streets of butcher
evidence of russian atrocities coming to
light following the liberation of this
town near kiev
ukrainian authorities say over 400
corpses have been found in areas retaken
by its forces
a visibly shaken president vladimir
zelensky visited butcher on monday
he called on russia to come to the
negotiation table before it's too late
the longer russia delays the talks
the worse it is for them
because every day when our troops
advance and reclaim territory we see
the images out of butcher have shocked
the world
u.s president joe biden vowed to
continue support for ukraine and echoed
calls by other leaders for an
international investigation you may
remember i got criticized for calling
putin a war criminal
or the truth of the matter to show what
happened to rufus
this warrants him he is a war criminal
but we have to gather the information we
have to continue to provide ukraine with
the weapons they need to continue the
fight
and we have to gather all the detail so
this could be an actual have a war crime
trial
eu commissioner ozla von der lyon said
in a tweet the european union was ready
to send investigation teams to ukraine
foreign minister sergey lavrov denied
his country's culpability and called the
dead of butcher a stage provocation
[Applause]
but the kremlin's denials are becoming
less believable with everybody retrieved
from the ruined cities left behind by
its retreating army
let's join dw correspondent nick
connolly who was in butcher earlier
welcome nick what did you see
i saw a city in shock city that
basically has been destroyed uh even
before it could be fully finished this
is a very young suburb of kiev lots of
high-rise new apartment blocks that have
been
basically
ruined while still under construction um
you see a lot of people under shell
shock happy to see outsiders because
they were cut off from the outside world
for basically a month
but a mix of kind of hope relief
and a very um
shocked energy people very keen to tell
their stories to share what they've been
through in the last few months
and we were
at
the main
grave site next to a church um we
believe based on what people there told
us that about 100 people are lying there
in several layers those right at the
bottom that you can see in parts were
just buried in what they were walking in
when
as the locals told us they were shot on
the streets and then collected by
neighbors and other ukrainian uh locals
who brought them there to get them off
the streets
in the middle there you've got people
who've basically been wrapped in a duvet
or some kind of
bed cover and then the top layer people
are in body bags um the locals told us
that they had tried as best they could
to collect the passports to or any other
kind of id that were on these people
when they were found on the streets to
be able to reconstruct who they were and
to let their next of kin know we went to
the cellar of a children's holiday camp
where the ukrainians say several people
were executed with their arms tied
behind their backs the bodies had been
recovered by the authorities today but
they were still
staying blood stains on the walls
bullets lying around clothes
um it's a very
um
extraordinary and disorienting place to
be and the most extraordinary because
you know the rest of ukraine and most
people here living in kiev like the
journalists were hearing the artillery
shells in the distance it's only 25
kilometers kind of direct line from
downtown kiev but they weren't able to
get there for weeks and weeks and weeks
there wasn't reliable phone or internet
connection for a long time so people
were hearing this were
fearing the worst we're hearing awful
things from people who managed to get
out but weren't able to actually go and
take a look at themselves until the last
few days
and it sounds from from what you're
saying then that there was no shortage
of people there to to witness what
actually happened
that's right and the ukrainian
authorities are now being very proactive
in trying to collect those eyewitness
accounts um
a few days ago we're in another part of
the kiev region where the ukrainians
have come back and retaking control in
recent days and as soon as you enter
that region you get an automatic text
message encouraging you to report
whatever you've experienced to a
government website um and even on a
local level um those people who'd
collected the bodies um talking about
their
attempt now to try and find those next
of kin to they have lists of the dead
that they found and now trying to now
they have internet you know in part for
the most part there still isn't internet
or mobile phone connection in butcher
but now trying to get back onto social
media to then try and find the relatives
of these people based on their names
based on the places where these people
were found um one of the most haunting
things i heard today was from an older
woman who had spent the most past month
hiding in her house scared of leaving
and she talked about her son-in-law who
had gone out to try and buy some food
and been shot um but not only that
they'd found him fairly quickly but they
weren't able to recover the body for
weeks because they were scared that you
know if they went out onto the roads
where it was dangerous that they would
also lose their lives um they were also
talking minds you know supposedly bodies
uh being uh
covered with minds or booby traps so
that you know there would be a direct
physical
uh danger threat to people's lives if
they tried to get those bodies back and
that they'd only been able to recover
that body in the last few days after
weeks of that body lying on the road
and a quick word about the russian
response nick sergey lavrov the foreign
minister has dismissed this as part of a
western disinformation so presumably we
were not going to expect any help from
the russian side in investigating these
deaths
i think that's a given but for now it
doesn't seem like they're advancing any
alternative explanations as to how these
people died um i think it's worth taking
a look back to 2014 and the donbass
conflict and the downing of the mh17 um
flight over donbass by what was then
later established a russian missile back
then the russian government came up with
new versions every couple of weeks that
were then soon discounted or just
ignored by their own side but i think
back then the tactic seems to have been
to advance um whatever it took any kinds
of kind of possible explanations to
distract from the situation on the
ground in the hope that eventually
people would lose interest and not
bother following it up but as we've seen
since the dutch authorities have spent
years investigating that finding out
down to the last person who was
responsible all down the chain of
command and then now advancing those
charges against people who will be tried
in absentia obviously they're in russia
they're not available to that court but
years of work did manage to achieve a
clear picture of what happened back then
in 2014 so i think the hope here in
ukraine will be that something similar
will be possible okay thank you for that
uh nick nick connolly
well nora love is emergency director the
international rescue committee and is
currently leading the team in ukraine
welcome to dw um have you i i wonder
been hearing or had you been hearing
rumors of these sorts of events as you
uh went about your your business
um i haven't been hearing but i mean irc
is shocked and appalled at this census
killing um the conflict in ukraine has
gone on too long and the international
community must step up its efforts to
find a diplomatic solution the civilian
lives must be protected um we can't
afford to be a witness to another crisis
like this
right and uh how of the people that
you've been helping are there reacted to
this news
i mean so i see we're focusing with our
local partners on stabilizing the health
systems in eastern ukraine uh we're
looking to support
people with cash and basic needs and
respond to the trauma as they move out
of some of these areas further central
and further west of ukraine to or even
on to european countries um so you know
we're focusing on that working with
providing pharmaceuticals medical
supplies and equipments and reinforcing
um the health actors through technical
support
um so you know we are trying to provide
the the services and the aid
where that's most needed
because we had heard some some terrible
things about uh food and water shortages
in the likes of kieva and mario paul so
are things they're now improving
i mean there there seems to be some
relief but you know we call irc calls
with other um actors to you know have
free access and and to provide the
services to
get these services back going in these
areas um we want you know the rules of
international law to be respected and
and just to have a sense of humanity um
throughout the
the country
you say that
you you're calling for for free access
to the areas what is hindering your
access at the moment
um well there still hasn't been
consistent free access to get in convoys
and other things like that so we're
calling on all actors to ensure that the
humanitarian
aid and access as according to
humanitarian laws is allowed um so we
just need people to respect those um
including the protection of civilian
lives and
infrastructure
okay thank you for joining us nora love
from the international rescue committee
thank you
well following the discovery of all
those bodies in nebuchad germany has
declared 40 officials at the russian
embassy in berlin to be undesirable
persons effectively expelling them from
the country france is also expelling a
number of russian diplomats german
foreign minister annalina bearbach said
germany would also boost its support to
ukraine's armed forces and tighten
economic sanctions against russia
the images of the past weekend have once
again highlighted a new brutal dimension
of this war
with the most serious war crimes and
crimes against humanity
and that is why i made it clear over the
weekend that we must not only close the
remaining loopholes in the sanctions
system
but that we must also intensively and
rigorously implement this package
and with regard to ukraine's
self-defense as i said we will now also
examine things that we have not examined
before
let's get more from dw political
correspondent thomas sparrow thompson
let me start with start with a simple
question so we're all clear germany's
call for even more sanctions this is a
direct result of these discoveries at
butcher
absolutely and something else that's a
direct result of the discoveries of
those bodies and that massacre in
butcher is the decision to expel those
40 diplomats with germany's interior
minister only a while ago
stressing that it's all about securing
germany maintaining
official security if you will public
security against russian lies and
propaganda as germany's interior
minister stress and we've also heard the
official russian reaction to all that
coming from the russian embassy here in
berlin
stressing that they presented their view
to german officials of what happened in
butcher they rejected germany's
announcement of those 40 diplomats being
expelled stressing that germany's
unfriendly actions would not be left
without consequences we still don't know
exactly what those consequences would be
but according to the russian officials
they stress that this basically damages
russian german relations even more and
makes dialogue even more difficult
between both countries from a german
perspective clearly a decision related
to what we are seeing from ukraine and
also an elena berbock the foreign
minister stressing that this is only the
beginning that more actions are actually
expected okay so
what other cards does germany have to
play because as you say there are
already stringent
measures in place
strengthening already existing sanctions
it's something that germany is
government and inaudible in particular
stressed but that is something that
germany will probably not do
unilaterally that's something that
germany will probably work hand in hand
with its european allies what germany is
still reluctant to do unlike some of its
european allies is to impose an embargo
on russian energy imports that something
that german government the german
government believes it would actually
harm germany more than it would harm
russia and that's why germany has said
that it needs more time before
supporting such a decision that it's not
entirely against it what it's entirely
against is doing it immediately because
that would certainly affect germany to
an extent that germany certainly does
not want in fact we've heard from german
officials in the past say that that
could lead to a recession to mass
unemployment to poverty so that's why
german officials in particular are so
reluctant to support an immediate
embargo on russian energy imports
thank you for that thomas dw political
correspondent thomas sparrow
well us president joe biden is one of
many international leaders describing
the events in butcher as a war crime
here he is talking with reporters after
arriving in washington on monday morning
you may remember i got criticized for
calling putin the war criminal
or the truth of the matter to show what
happened to rufus
this warrants him he is a war criminal
but we have to gather the information we
have to continue to provide ukraine with
the weapons they need to continue the
fight
and we have to gather all the detail so
this could be an actual have a war crime
trial this guy is brutal
let's join christine berzina who's a
senior fellow at the german marshall
fund of the united states where she also
heads its russia task force welcome to
dw and what's your thoughts on this uh
given what we've we've seen so far war
crime or faked images
it's very clear from uh the
the international press presence for
example that went in to bucha also over
the weekend that this isn't a faked uh
massacre and satellite footage also
confirms looking down on bucha where
some of the placement of these bodies
were uh that this is there's other
verification of the authenticity of
these images and of these attacks and
the gravity
of these crimes uh is really glaring for
the international community for the
united states for europe
and it takes the moral outrage to a new
level so the questions that come next
are what to do about it clearly
the existing sanctions and even the
ukrainian military victories of pushing
the russians back
are not enough to stop
this kind of behavior so how does the
west signal to russia
and to the russian military to those
soldiers who are choosing
to make such horrible
devastating crimes against against women
against uh against civilians of all kind
that uh they are wrong and that's where
the new rounds of sanctions that are
being talked about for later this week
come into play right but also
it's just so horrible
let me let me just interrupt there
because we'll talk about what possibly
those sanctions might be but
what are they for beyond punishing
russia is there a consensus about what
these sanctions should achieve because
if their purpose is to end this war
people might ask well why have they
waited to to to turn the volume up to 10
as it were
the purpose of sanctions is a frequent
topic of conversation and even today
jake sullivan and from the white house
talking about the potential for new
sanctions was using the terminology of
raising the cost of having costs against
russia for its behavior so
the
it is important for russia to see
that these actions in particular are not
only seen and said you know that is sad
too bad uh but they will impose they
will have a cost to
russia immediately there's a longer term
question which is the war crimes piece
which is what president biden spoke
about and many european leaders have
which is a necessity to collect all of
this evidence and then take this to um
either the international criminal court
or a different venue that is not not yet
decided in order to prosecute uh
president putin
for these war crimes that is a longer
term process the question is what can be
done this week right now that this is
clear what is
how do you how do you punish russia this
week right okay so we're talking about
potentially extending the the sanctions
that are already on the table but
however this war ends in a deal or by
one side bombing the other to a
standstill and claiming victory
does russia then just resume its former
position on the international stage on
the u.n security council and go back to
business as usual
very hard uh to imagine how after
behavior like this russia can resume
standing in europe or in north america
yet there are many countries uh that
abstained from voting against russia in
across the international assembly uh
china is backing russia still
right now and so russia does have
relatively normal business with a few
countries india for example uh big
countries india the united arab emirates
china places that have very healthy
economies uh and that are seeking
cooperation so there yeah i couldn't
imagine uh business as usual but ibs i
find it incredibly difficult to see how
there can be normal relations between
russia and europe or
north america other global democracies
that have taken a stand against russia
right now
given these horrific actions
the uh which is you know the question
would sanctions of some kind come down
at which point what would be the
conditions necessary in order to
normalize but i think we are very very
far from that and when you look to
russian history russia has not had a
process for
reckoning with its misdeeds in the way
that other countries have in germany the
nuremberg trials and
decades worth of educational reforms and
conversation have led to
a kind of social
readjustment um and understanding uh
about the problems with the third reich
after the south of africa after
apartheid there were truth and
reconciliation councils that again
forced talking about and understanding
um
the the
the violations that happened and yet
russia after the end of the soviet union
does not have a policy of of looking at
the stalinist era or prior imperial era
through the
various purges and deportations and
hunger campaigns and famines and murders
and mass arrests
none of that has been denounced truly
instead stalin is glorified by president
putin the imperial history is
is glorified and the same rhetoric of
cleansing society is back in play so
what would need to happen in russia for
some kind of future normal relationship
is for there to be a societal
understanding of the unacceptability of
this
that's very clear i hope we get to talk
again christine berzina from the german
marshall fund thank you so much
thank
you so let's look at the potential legal
ramifications of these discoveries at
butcher professor yvonne mcdermott reese
is professor of law at swansea
university in the united kingdom welcome
to dw
on the face of it if what's been
discovered in butcher is what it appears
to be would that be a war crime
potentially yes i mean um
it could even reach the level of
genocide uh war crimes or crimes against
humanity so these are three distinct
categories of international crimes
genocide is um is defined as any one of
a number of acts including killing and
committed with the intention to destroy
a national ethnic racial or religious
group in whole or in part
so
potentially
if it could be shown that these acts
were committed with the intention of of
destroying the ukrainian people in buche
then that could reach the level of
genocide
war crimes are serious violations of the
laws relating to iron conflict we've
seen several potential war crimes and
obviously everyone is entitled to the
presumption of innocence and this would
have to be adjudicated by an independent
and impartial tribunal but potentially
some of the things we've seen come out
reach the threshold of war crimes as do
um crimes against humanity appear to be
applicable here so these are crimes uh
committed against the civilian
population um as part of a widespread or
systematic attack against a civilian
population
and and where in all that would vladimir
uh putin be potentially culpable
okay um well potentially
uh
let's say theoretically we have a trial
before the international criminal court
the icc seeks to prosecute those who are
deemed most responsible and there are a
number of modes of liability that are
set out in statute of the international
criminal court so these include ordering
inducing soliciting these crimes to be
committed but importantly i think in the
case of vladimir putin um
there's superior responsibility so those
who are in charge of an armed forces or
or others um
bear responsibility for the crimes that
they've committed where they fail to
prevent those crimes from happening or
to punish them and appropriately where
where they have been committed okay but
we're talking about the law but we're
also talking about politics and if this
war ends in some sort of peace deal
isn't the political reality that the
prospect of criminal prosecutions is
likely to be bargained away
um i think that's unlikely um
politically i i can't see
the ukrainian uh side agreeing to that
but i think legally as well it's pretty
problematic the idea of amnesties for
serious international crimes so
theoretically perhaps you know we might
have some sort of truth and
reconciliation commission and as part of
that there might be some agreement that
lower
level perpetrators aren't prosecuted but
in by the ukrainian authorities um
that might be problematic though because
these international crimes genocide
crimes against humanity and war crimes
attract what we call universal
jurisdiction so that means that any
country in the world potentially could
could try those who were deemed
responsible for these international
crimes um i think it would also be
problematic in terms of and the
international criminal court so
even if that were an outcome of peace
talks between ukraine and russia
i can't see the prosecutor of the
international criminal court respecting
such an amnesty and i think he'd be
quite likely to say it's my
responsibility to prosecute those who
are most responsible for the most
serious international crimes and that's
what i'm going to do
okay that's very clear thank you so much
for outlining that for us professor
yvonne mcdermott rhys from swansea
university
thank you